louise heal the youngster
will begin his warm-ups this will be a
sixth big league start he's acquitted
himself well two point eight eighty or a
25 innings 32 strikeouts too many walks
with 15 three home runs opponents hit
183
against him
strike three
slider clipped the outside corner straw
down on strikes now the right-handed
hitting oscar mercado swings ropes one
to left down the line it goes takes one
bounce ricochets up against the wall
gallo throwing towards second but in
sliding with a double is oscar mercado
so two ounce with a runner a third and
here is fran mel reyes the one two swing
and a miss
two strikeouts for heel in the first no
runs ahead aaron savali is going to be
your indian starting pitcher brought to
you by northeast ohio four dealers
savali 10-4 on the air making his 18th
start just this third since coming off
the list savali is five and one on the
road the indians are seven and one in
his uh starts on the road so maybe
that's just what he needs here's the two
two
and the pitch is hit in the ear to deep
center straw back a way back over his
head one hop to the monument park wall
and la mayu coasts into second with a
double so here's aaron judge he homered
last night two on nobody out no score in
the first
little jam show it is
bingo one
and two perfect that's what he was
looking for made the pitch started him
off fastball away jammed him inside got
the easy ground ball double play
uh oh deep right field but not deep
enough
that short porch scares you every time
ramirez making the catch the yankees
threaten they do not score here is
harold ramirez to start the second
swing and a miss that slider is working
three strikeouts for heal chang batting
210 seven homers 28 rbis
the pitch swung in and blasted high
deep to left way out of here
and so you chang hammers his eighth home
run and the indians have a one-nothing
lead here in inning number two the 2-2
swing and a miss
again on a slider four strikeouts for
heal the set in the 2-2
oh what a curveball strike three called
and sanchez was frozen brett gardner
steps in runner goes throw by hedges
it's a good one and they got him labor
torres erased for the fifth time this
year and after two innings it's
cleveland one new yorker runners on
first and second for reyes
going to work out of it high pop-up
and urchella puts it away to retire
foreign no runs a hit
two men left heel battling bottom of the
third brett gardner was batting last
inning when torres was gunned down
trying to steal
a swing and a miss gardner strikes out
savali's second strikeout the pitch
swaying a little floater to right but
right there to catch that line drive but
not a smoked line drive here's harold
ramirez and boy aaron savali lights out
through three one nothing indians lead
the games now it's first and second with
only one out and austin hedges will come
to the plate swinging a miss slider
didn't come close missed that one by
about a foot and a half two down two way
and here is a lovely hitter andre's
jimenez
did he go around yes he did jimenez down
on strike so a nice bounce back from
heal
the 3-2
called strike three as he dropped an off
speed pitch right in there
two up two down and here comes giancarlo
stanton
goes to right field it's pretty deep but
not deep enough
ramirez grabs it hitting over now we
have an update on joey gala meredith
what do you know michael i just learned
that he exited this afternoon's game
with neck tightness and here's a look at
last night you can actually see him in
the dugout grabbing the back of his neck
right there so you wonder exactly what
that means for joey galloway of course
we'll have more on the post game show
and this was today on a swing you can
see he was in some level of discomfort
there it is tightness in the neck
the two one
popped up
sanchez
drops the ball mercado was walking back
to the dugout and now he's going to get
another swing and the crowd boos that
was a difficult play because it came
back on sanchez he reached back couldn't
make the catch into the sun and mercado
then gets plunked and he's going to take
first base so it could have been two
outs and nobody on now it's a runner on
first and
one out
and that's ball four so ramirez is
aboard two on one out and here comes
aaron boone
and that's it for luis heals fran mill
reyes with runners at first and second
and only one out here's the 1-0 swung on
line drive base hit left field down the
line it goes up against the wall mercado
will score racing to third and being
held there is ramirez as the throw comes
into third into second with an rbi
double fran mil reyes and the indians
lead it two nothing bases loaded one out
and the man who hit the home run is
first time up you chang getting ready to
bat
lying to right field that's going to get
down into the corner it goes ramirez
scores reyes scores
and big harold stops at third it's a two
run double for you chang in a four
nothing indians lead it's a three run
fifth here's owen miller
right back up the middle and through
another run will score as harold ramirez
comes home chance stopping at third and
owen miller delivers with his 16th run
batted in on the year and now it's andre
simenes as the infield drops back
in the air right field pretty well hit
it's deep judges out of room it's out of
here
exclamation point
andreas jimenez with just his third home
run of the season and it's a seven run
fifth first libra here's fran miel reyes
one for three with an rbi double 01
pitch is swung on hit high and deep to
left back goes weight he's at the track
he's at the wall it sails out of here
fran mill race with the indians third
home run a towering blast to left off
andrew heaney and the indians now lead
it 10 to nothing aaron judd's open
stance deep in the box he hits out of a
crouch
there it is
how about that what a job by aaron
cevalle on a 3-1 pitch he gets an inning
ending double play giancarlo has flied
out twice the right hand is 3-1 swung on
hit in the air to right center and deep
back and that ball is in the bullpen
gone
a home run for stanton a
stantonian home run and the yankees now
trail 10-1 giancarlo
rossi wall still follow
ramirez has walked twice he's over two
he'll swing it right-handed the pitch
swung in and hammered a deep left down
the line it goes it is a
fair ball and a home run into the second
deck jose ramirez
with the indians fourth home run
is 34th
as le mayo walks and that'll bring up
luke voight
3-2
high drive left field that ball is going
to go
see ya a long drive into the siege for
luke voight it's a two-run shot and the
indians lead 11-3
[Applause]
so two-run home run for boyd his 11th of
the year
so we go to the top of the order dj
lemayo has two hits he has walked and
scored a run
there's a ground ball to you chang
hook it the indians even the series in
the big apple at a game of peace as they
thump the yankees 11-3 this afternoon